why are young scant aegis in quotes are
they similarly contagious and other
primates do you think ideas expressed
before a yawn might piggyback on the
yawn to be spread more effectively in a
group wow it's so interesting well I
don't know about the last piece yeah I
did have a kind of a riff on yawns but
it's been years and I don't have it at
the tip of my tongue there is I think
something about state of mind and that
effectively yawns are something that
spreads because it's like a feeling of
security sufficient that sleep would be
acceptable and so you can imagine oh you
know prize it could be an indicator of
trust even yeah it's an indicator of I
perceive that this is secure and that
spreads to the group and so anyway that
raises all kinds of questions and it
maybe predict certain things about the
way it functions but it is fascinating
and yes it is contagious in multiple
different kinds of creatures now I
wondered at the time that I was working
on this whether it was contagious
between types of creatures which would
be very interesting yeah and I don't I
don't remember whether there's any
evidence yeah I have never seen an
analysis of that anecdotally it doesn't
really look like it you know when when
we've been watching you know wild
primates for instance and they they go
on a yawning bout it doesn't seem to
track in to us are there things are you
know when our cats start yawning it
spreads through them but doesn't spread
to the dog yes that's you know that's
anecdote but I am I would put money on
but not a lot of money on the idea that
actually that has not been looked at
yeah I'd cross species contagion of
yawning but within species contagion yes
yeah at least some so it at least some
other primates and seems to be at least
domestic companions interesting how
widespread it is though which suggests
one of two things it's all--it's early
mammals still widespread yeah right yeah
but the question is is it convergently
widespread or is it ancient and we've
all inherited it from
some yawning ancestor yawning tree shrew
yeah something like that
[Music]